-My first guest is a six-time
Grammy nominated artist.
He's one of the best dudes
on Earth.
His new show, "Post Malone's
Celebrity World Pong League,"
premieres November 18th
on Messenger's new
Watch Together feature.
Here is Post Malone! Posty!
-Hello, everybody.
-Yeah.
-What's going on, bubba?
-You look good, bud.
You look great, actually.
Where are you right now, pal?
-I'm home in Utah right now.
-Utah?
-Kind of just relaxing
and trying to stay
out of trouble.
You know?
-Yeah.
You're like in
the mountain air and --
-Feels good. You know, I smoke
too much, too.
So the air really gets to me.
So I like -- [ Deep breath ]
Every time I go up a set of
stairs, I can't --
-Yeah, you learn a
lesson every time you breathe.
-Yes, sir, I suppose.
-Have you been --
I know you probably have,
you can't stop.
Have you been working
on new music?
-Yes, sir.
You know, it's --
it's been a while, you know,
getting into the studio
and stuff after, you know, kind
of -- I remember the beginning
of the whole COVID thing,
and then
when they finally opened up the
studio so I could go in
and work, and lately
I've just been, you know,
trying to mess around and
make some cool stuff
and some funky stuff.
And I think we're making some
awesome stuff right now.
-As a songwriter, is it
harder to make music during
a time like this, or does this
kind of push you
to actually make music?
-I don't know.
I suppose, you know, maybe not
harder, but maybe different.
Like I've had more time to be,
I guess, introspective.
You know, kind of not being able
to go out.
-Hey, Post, I'm sorry,
I think there's a burglar
trying to
break into your house.
-Oh, yeah, these guys --
I don't know,
they just hang around
the house.
-You pay them to
break into your house?
-Dude, you ruined the bit.
This was supposed to be the
whole bit for the show.
[ Laughter ]
-It's almost like Cato.
-We'll give them the guest
house over there, so...
-You pay them to break
in just to make sure
your security system works.
[ Laughter ]
Dude, I like --
-Worst guest of all time.
He looked cool, man.
He's got no face.
He's like --
Dude, I like that character,
man, no face.
That guy scared me.
Man, he was rad.
Hey, I want to talk about your
new show, it's called
"Post Malone's
Celebrity World Pong League."
-Sure.
-It premieres next week on
Messenger's new Watch Together
feature.
Which is a really fun feature,
by the way.
What made you think
of this idea?
-Umm, I guess just being
drunk, playing beer pong.
You know, I figured eventually
we want to kind of
make it like a league and do
like -- I don't --
maybe not arenas off rip,
but like middle school
basketball courts.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah?
-I'm sure...
-You know, small-scale
type deal, but I want to make it
every city has a team,
where like the best
schools, you know,
the best beer pong players
from each school
have a team and it's a whole
bracket like the NFL
or the NBA
or something.
That's down the line.
You know, but this show
is more about just
kicking it with a couple of
friends and just, you know,
talking, shooting the breeze,
and just playing beer pong,
getting a little drunk,
you know.
It's a lot of fun.
-I heard a story, and
it has to be true,
but did you challenge
Patrick Mahomes,
Super Bowl MVP Patrick Mahomes,
to a game of beer pong,
and what went actually down?
And was there a bet?
-Yeah. He challenged me,
and I was so game and I was
like, "Let's go."
We were backstage,
I think we were in KC,
but we were backstage,
and Patrick Mahomes
and Travis Kelce walk in
and they were like,
"Let's play some pong."
They had just won
the Super Bowl.
And I'm like, well, you know,
there's no way
I'm going to say no
because in actuality,
I'm the best player, I know.
-Mm-hmm.
-But you know, we got down
the line a couple games,
and I was starting to get drunk
and they get beating us
and beating us and beating us.
And then I was like,
"You know what?
Let's keep playing.
And if you win,
I'll get a tattoo
of a Kansas City Chiefs logo,
and y'all's autograph
on my arm, as well."
-Their autographs?
-Yeah, you want to see it?
-I can't believe you
did this, man.
Dude, this is --
Oh, my gosh. Wait. Move --
-That's the good stuff
right there.
-Oh, my gosh.
-This is on me forever.
[ Laughter ]
-Only you would do that.
That is so funny, man.
Did they freak out?
-Yeah, he was like, "You don't
have to really do it."
And I was like,
"Oh, come on, man,
let me do it.
I told you I would do it."
-"I told you,
I'm a man of my word.
I'm a man of my word."
-Jimmy, will you say hi
to my stepmom?
-Yeah. Please.
I would love to.
I would be honored.
Yeah. Mom?
Where's stepmom?
-You're always meeting moms.
-I know.
-The moms dig you.
-Yeah.
-This is Jodie.
-Oh, come on.
What, are you kidding me?
Hi, nice to -- come on!
Nice to meet you.
Are you having fun out there
in Utah?
-We love Utah.
Great, great time.
-It really is good. All right,
good. Stay safe, okay?
-Thanks, you too.
-I love you, Jodie.
-Are you kidding me?
Dude, how cute.
That's so fun.
-She's the best.
-You played beer pong against
a lot of famous people.
Is there anyone else that
we'd be surprised to learn
isn't really that good?
-Umm, trying to think.
I played with K.D.,
I played with Kevin Durant.
-He's not good?
-He was good.
Yeah, but he's a cheater,
because his wingspan is like
ten feet.
-He's a leaner.
-His elbows were always
over the table every time.
-Yeah, no, no, no.
That's cheat--
Yeah, no, no, no. I don't --
Dude, no, you gotta
know the rules.
-You can't help it, though.
You know --
If you're so -- you're so --
Your wingspan is just
so long, you can't help it.
-You can't dunk the ball.
-Drake's no good.
Drake's no good.
-Where did you play Drake?
-In Toronto, I think.
-Home court.
-He came backstage
at the show in Toronto,
and we started playing
beer pong.
And I was just like,
man, he sucks.
-"Dude, you're terrible."
-If you see this, come meet me
again, we'll play again.
But he was terrible.
-You've beaten me before
in beer pong, and I was happy.
I was actually -- it was a badge
of honor to lose to you.
But I have an idea
for a rematch.
What if you and I competed
in every drinking game ever
in one game?
-I'm ready to go.
-Post Malone and I are
going head to head...
-Let me know.
-...in every drinking game ever,
when we come back.
More "Tonight Show."
Stick around.